All right, so we're going to look at some
material today from two of these new Republican
members of the U.S. House who were elected
in November.
Today, we're going to be looking at an interview
with Republican Congressman Madison Cawthorn.
And shortly we're going to look at some tweets
from Republican Congresswoman Lauren Bobert.
And here's what I really want everyone to
get from this among.
Yes, how to identify and defeat really bad
arguments.
That's important.
But there's a bigger story here.
These people whose material we're going to
look at momentarily, they got elected writing
the Trump scam train.
They didn't run on policy.
They didn't run on being experts in a particular
issue or on certain types of subject matter.
They ran on merely playing Trumpy and characters,
riding the wave of support for Trump ism that
exists to a greater degree in some parts of
the country and in some districts in the United
States.
And the problem with electing what are essentially
characters playing a political acting role
is they don't know anything about anything.
There's no substance to them whatsoever.
Now, in general, in American politics, there's
a huge role for personality.
You all know this personality, appearance,
public speaking ability, ability to raise
money.
There's a whole bunch of stuff that in American
politics on both sides, it can get people
elected who are not the most qualified and
doesn't mean they're actually equipped to
deal with policy in depth.
But this has never been more acutely so than
among this latest wave of people who got elected
merely for being pro Trump cultists in areas
that have a lot of pro Trump cultist voters.
So let's get right into this.
New Republican Congressman Madison Cawthorn
has been very loudly saying, first of all,
that he goes armed to the House of Representatives,
but also that there was likely fraud and wrongdoing
in states like Georgia, Arizona, Pennsylvania
and others because of mail and voting and
other stuff that Trump has also been repeating.
You all know the stories.
It took two months between the election and
the inauguration, two and a half months of
them repeating these same bogus, tired stories.
And Cawthorn actually voted against accepting
certain states election results in the House
of Representatives on January 6th.
So Cawthorn goes on CNN and he's interviewed
by Pamela Brown, who came very prepared and
is asked about the fact that his arguments
for voting not to certify some states apply
to the state in which he was elected, North
Carolina as well.
But he never claimed that there were problems
in his state, even though the guidelines he
has a problem with in other states apply just
as much to North Carolina.
This go this could not have gone any worse
for Madison Cawthorn.
He's going to have to stop doing these interviews.
But before we get to that part, here's Pamela
Brown challenging Madison Cawthorn to cite
evidence of election fraud.
She says, and I love this, you must have so
many specific instances of of of evidence
of fraud.
Right.
And he did not utter are some specific examples
that informed this bold decision, this audacious
decision, even after the riots, to decertify
the results.
You must have seen some concrete evidence.
Well, Pam, the things that I was not objecting
to the election on behalf of wars, things
like Dominion, voting machines, changing ballots,
or these U-Haul trucks pulling up filled with
ballots for Joe Biden as president.
The thing I was objecting for is things like
like I said, in the state of Wisconsin, particularly
in the town of Madison, there was a an appointed
official in that town who actually went against
the will of the state legislature and created
ballot drop boxes, which is basically ballot
harvesting that was happening in the parks.
But this was all litigated.
You know, that the Trump campaign litigated
all of this, more than 60 cases, and they
lost either.
The cases were dismissed, the Trump campaign
withdrew, or they never brought a case because
they didn't have the evidence to back it up.
Indeed, I believe specifically and this is
the one that I debated on behalf of on the
House floor in Wisconsin that was never heard
because they dismissed it because of standing.
Now, I don't believe that that is concrete
enough.
Well, there were three trumps in Wisconsin,
but you never you ended up not actually voting
against Wisconsin.
It was just Arizona.
And Pennsylvania didn't have the Senate votes.
But, OK, so he didn't object because of machines
or massive ballot dumps coming out of the
back of trucks.
OK, but in Wisconsin, some official created
drop boxes.
But as Pamela Brown points out, that was all
litigated.
It had no merit.
But the most important is he keeps talking
about Wisconsin.
He didn't end up voting against certification
in Wisconsin.
He voted against certification in other states.
This is so incoherent, we'd need an hour to
tease it all apart.
And it gets even worse.
Three, Trump appoint a judge actually throughout
these cases because of merit, it was because
of merit.
There were three Trump appointed judges out
of all of these judges and the more than 60
cases that were tossed out.
You keep talking about Wisconsin.
I'm still not hearing any specific examples
of fraud.
If you would just tell us, what are the specific
examples you saw fraud.
Because when you think of fraud, you think
of a vote, you're slipping one pass the election
official or a vote was stolen.
Somehow it didn't count.
Did you see that specifically?
No, Pam, like I said, that's not the reason
I contested the election.
So this is already just a disaster for this
guy.
And then Pamela Brown points out the contradiction
between Cawthorn saying he has issues with
the changes to election rules in Wisconsin,
where his own state where he was elected,
North Carolina, made similar changes because
of the pandemic.
Look at this.
This if you have an aversion to cringe, walk
out of the room right now, keep focusing on
was focusing on Wisconsin.
But there were several battleground states
that you contested to that you talked about.
There were several that President Trump had
lost.
So it's interesting you're focusing on Wisconsin,
but would you apply the same issues you had
with these battleground states to your own
state of North Carolina?
Because North Carolina also changed a lot
of the rules even after voters had started
voting.
Why didn't you have concerns about your own
home state of North Carolina?
Well, you know, I'm actually not aware of
the laws that were changed inside of North
Carolina.
I believe we had a very safe and a very secure
election here.
Oh, wait, what?
North Carolina was fine, safe, secure, even
though they did lots of the same things.
But North Carolina simply didn't become part
of the narrative.
And it keeps getting even worse, if you can
imagine.
So there's no reason to contest that.
Yeah, there were several rules, one of which
is to extend when the mail in ballots could
arrive, I believe, by around seven days.
That was one.
And there were a couple of others as well
that that were changed even after people started
voting.
So I'm just wondering if you're so concerned
about these rules being changed with the election,
why why wouldn't you focus on your own home
state of North Carolina?
I mean, you're telling me that your concern
really is about election integrity, not politics,
not the results of the election, right?
That is absolutely correct.
I didn't do this or any one man or against
any one man.
OK, so North Carolina, though, the same issues
you've had and you've expressed about the
battleground states, those are the same issues
that are in your own state of North Carolina.
And North Carolina actually did have mail
in ballot fraud in twenty eighteen.
So.
So you're not concerned about your home state
and whether you were duly elected by your
own standards?
Well, I'll tell you, because of the mail in
ballot fraud that happened in the midterms
here in twenty eighteen, I believe our election
integrity standards here in North Carolina
are some of the greatest in the country.
I think they should apply this metric all
over the country, but that's just my opinion.
So he doesn't know anything about it, or at
least claims to.
But it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
His election was definitely accurate because
he won.
So he definitely won fair and square.
And then later in the sort of wrap up to this
complete farce of an interview, he admits,
yeah, the election wasn't fraudulent.
I did what I do, what I could do to push back,
but it actually was not a fraudulent election.
Well, but then, Madison, why did you push
back?
Can you now say that the election was not
stolen, that it wasn't a fraudulent election?
Yes, I think I would say that the election
was not fraudulent.
The Constitution allowed for us to be able
to push back as much as we could.
And I did that to the amount of the constitutional
limits that I had at my disposal.
So now I would say to Joseph R. Biden is our
president and you have no regrets?
No, I do not have any regrets.
OK, listen, Republican Congressman Madison
Cawthorn, thank you for coming on.
So either he's going to need some serious
media training or he will have to stop doing
these interviews.
And this is what happens when we elect characters
to play lawmakers on TV.
It's not about governing.
It's the new version of winning a reality
TV show.
That's all it is.
And Pamela Brown so easily dismantles this
guy to the point of it being humiliating for
him.
And you almost start to feel bad for the kid,
except that he chose to do this and people
voted him in and now he can wield power and
do a lot of damage.
So it isn't necessarily a new phenomenon in
our political history that incompetent people
get elected.
That's not new.
And we've seen that on both sides.
But the way in which the cult of.
Trump has been weaponized to propel completely
clueless people who have no business even
being on the House floor, like it's not even
about what they do, they have no business
being on the House floor.
Their big concern is bringing guns to the
House floor.
It is particularly pernicious right now.
Now, contrast this.
If you want to think about someone who's the
opposite of people like Madison Cawthorn and
Lauren Bobert, who will talk about think about
Jamie Raskin, OK?
You don't have to agree with everything Jamie
Raskin does.
You can say Jamie Raskin is not progressive
enough or whatever.
Jamie Raskin is a guy who cares about policy
and depth and brings a depth of knowledge
about the issues.
And he can talk about the.
He is a sort of politician's politician.
And he suffered a tragic loss recently with
the death of one of his children.
But he comes to mind as the antithesis to
these clueless reality show characters.
Let's now talk about Lauren Bobber.